we already established when you say what
a Muslim is is one who submits to The
God Who is absolutely singular he's not
a statute and he's not a father correct
exactly from Ab okay so it does matter
if I call him father right okay so we
all know when Christians call call the
fa when they say the father they we all
know it's a translation cuz in the not a
translation that's literally what the
word is it's not a translation that's
what the word is okay so you want to
tell me in the Aramaic when the
scriptures were the word in Aramaic is
Aba it's literally ABA we have it in the
Bible it's not ABA sorry I can't what
yeah it's not ABA it's not ABA yeah so
what is it and and and and uh and wa
wait wait wait stop stop stop don't go
anywhere
else I'm here I'm here all right good
what's the word for father and Aramaic
since it's not ABA good Lord okay so
okay so do you want me to search search
it and tell you what yeah yeah search
tell me what it is okay the word father
in Aramaic two seconds take as much as
you need okay so it means IL I don't
know how to pronounce it they say you
didn't put in you put in God you didn't
put in Father put in Father what is the
arama word so exactly if I put in Father
it means ABA but you know they they
didn't call them they didn't call God
ABA you know it because wa hold on a
second hold on a second but he did
though literally the word ABA is in the
Bible where Jesus calls God ABA hello hi
can you hear me yes yes hi how are you
I'm pretty good thank you how are you
I'm good thank you so basically Salam
answered the question why is the what is
the inil sorry no you didn't okay can I
ask you a question he kind of he kind of
said it's not the Bible but then kind of
said it was the Bible okay okay um can I
ask you a question as long as it's helps
us learn what the angil is okay um I
don't if it will actually okay I don't
know if it will make a difference but um
I believe that Jesus is a Palestinian
Muslim do you believe that of course not
okay why is that why should I believe it
why should I believe that he was a
muslim okay what does a Muslim mean you
tell me okay so a Muslim means a someone
who submits his will to God someone who
submits his will all right hold on just
one one second one second just hold that
thought hold that thought let me just
kind of change this background up a bit
because you are hitting on something
important and I don't I need the
background to match so let's just make
sure we are in order like e and
gentlemen all right so let's go ahead
here we go all right so Muslim is one
who submits the will of God you said yes
when you
say to God what God are you talking
about specifically okay so I'm saying
God okay so me as a Muslim I would say
Allah but Allah means god so
okay so so let me just like for example
if I were to say that I submit my will
to God Allah LA but the god that I'm
talking about is a statute in my closet
that I worship and prostrate to am I a
Muslim no why not because you have to
you sub because what does God that's a
statue that's different CU we're talking
about we're talking about monotheism
here that is monotheism monism is the
belief in one God so my one God is a
statute I'm a monotheist yeah no how
could how could you say that because
you're you're you're believing in a
statue but at the same time it's a
statue it's not it's not God so so from
an abrahamic perspective okay so so what
you're saying is is that that the god
that you're talking about has very
specific qualities is that correct yeah
I don't I don't understand why I feel
like this you're taking everything in
Circus cuz it's really clear
submits everyone know even the
Christians what's the first
commandment slow down again the reason
why what you I'm showing you that what
you say is not actually as clear as you
think it is when you say anyone who
submits to God is a Muslim and I say oh
wow okay I submit to God but my God is a
statue but I submit to God my God's a
statute am I a Muslim you say no okay so
yeah can I can I answer yeah yeah so
that's why we we take stuff from what
from authentic sources like the
dictionary so what does God mean Allah
when we're talking about God is God is
any concept of a deity that's what
that's what a God is is a deity anything
that you deem a deity can be a God to
you right now it doesn't mean that it's
the true God because you're it sounds
like to me that you have a particular
idea yeah exactly so so yeah exactly so
what you're saying but us from Abra
view notam view but you're an Islamic
view okay okay fair enough but from our
view what what do we understand how do
we take this yes that's yes that's what
I'm from our view yeah okay I'm not
considered with you as but from your
view or from a Jew's view what no not
mine not mine yours as a as a Muslim
when you say God what are you talking
about Allah one God that's it like the
same the same commandment from Jesus the
first commandment stop stop stop stop
stop because one God doesn't tell me
anything because again my statute is
only one statute it's only one God that
I'm talking about yeah but how can you
believe in one exactly how can you
believe in one God when you have a
statue so this is that's my one God
that's my one God yeah so you chose one
God the statue okay exactly so why are
you taking it this in circles we said
we're focusing from an abrahamic View
but no no because you're not from an
abrahamic you're from a Muslim I'm not
yes I understand I clear we cleared that
two minutes ago brother Abraham is not a
Muslim brother brother we cleared that
two minutes ago could you please like
rela just just take a deep breath
we're you have Isaac Isaac yeah you have
an idea when you say submit to God what
you mean by that is specifically the god
of Islam that's described in the Quran
right yeah okay so my okay my view is
the same as the every everyone from as I
said we're going in circuits again
everyone from I'm not trying to go in
circles I'm I'm right on the point when
you say God you're talking about the God
that's described in the Quran right yes
I'm talking about the God that is is
described in the Quran and that is
described that by by the act the true
Christians and the true true Jews okay
good right so specifically the god
that's described in the Quran let's give
some characteristics okay so like for
example he's only one right he's he
doesn't beget nor is he begotten right
he has no children right yeah you know
that yes okay so he's not a father in
any sense right yes of course how how
could you make a god a father or a son
or we don't even got to do that I got
you yeah he ABS he's absolutely one he's
not a father in any sense yeah yes
merciful yeah okay boom so that's who
we're talking about okay so can you show
me wait what's the point here could you
just back about I'm about to show you
the point now here it now that we
understand what you mean when you say a
Muslim is one who submits to God
specifically The God Who is not a father
in any sense who's absolutely one in in
his Essence right singular is only one
that God you have to submit to that God
to you're repeat you're repeating the
you been rep so I need so this what I
need you to do I need you to show me
that Jesus submitted to this God that
you just described who is not a father
in any sense and is absolutely one show
me that Jesus believed and submitted to
that God okay so exactly you didn't back
my statement you're coming you're coming
you're you're you're you're asking me
about what Jesus did we just said is is
Jesus a Palestinian Muslim what does a
Muslim mean someone who submits his will
to God the first commandment in the
Bible what is the first commandment in
the Bible may I ask you the first
commandment in the Bible is let there be
light okay okay how is that a
commandment let let let there God is
commanding light to come out that's in
Genesis one okay I don't think that's
what I read well you probably haven't
read the Bible no no no I I I I read the
I've been reading some of it because I
have Christian friends so I go I go with
them to their maybe you're talking about
are you talking about the the Ten
Commandments in the Torah what's the
first of the Ten Commandments cuz that's
that's uh yeah you would know better
sorry because I don't I don't want to
just get your Bible I don't want you to
be get offend offended if I got it wrong
so if I may ask you what's the 10 yeah
the first so all right so you're yeah
you're talking so the Ten Commandments
are special set of Commandments that God
wrote on Stone and gave to Moses I think
that's what you're talking about I am
the Lord your
God yeah so why did you bring why did
you bring the other statement first you
know me because you asked me what is the
first commandment in the Bible that's
what you as so so so if this if this is
coming out from God I am the Lord your
God it means we all know there is only
one God whoever you call him the Father
the different different names but we all
know we
all hold on it does matter it does
matter what you call I'll tell you why
I'll tell you why stop stop stop stop
Isaac stop you just told me that if I
call my one God the a statute then I'm
not submitting to God see a I didn't see
a said look this is where you're taking
he just said it doesn't matter what I
call him please brother brother can we
have a normal conversation because I
really want to go somewhere here and I I
really want to understand your point and
I want you to understand my point we
can't go somewhere if we don't have a
foundation together we we clearly have a
foundation I clearly told you what is
the first commandment you know it but
you didn't tell me you told me you told
me something else you know I'm speaking
I told you the first commandment that
you asked for but it appears that you
were asking about the first of the ten
commands brother brother brother can't
take me and brother please please just
stop stop stop Isaac it sounds like
you're not getting what's happening here
it's not about you just you just said
look we already established when you say
what a Muslim is is one who submits to
The God Who is absolutely singular he's
not a statute and he's not father
correct exactly from Ab okay so it does
matter if I call him father right okay
so we all know when Christians call call
the fa when they say the father they we
all know it's a translation cuz in the
ACT it's not a translation that's
literally what the word is it's not a
translation that's what the word is okay
so you want to tell me in the Aramaic
when the scriptures were the word in
Aramaic is Aba it's literally ABA we
have it in the Bible it's not ABA sorry
I can't what yeah it's not ABA it's AB
yeah so what is it and and and and uh
wait wait wait stop stop stop don't go
anywhere
else I'm here I'm here all right good
what's the word for father in arama
since it's not ABA good Lord okay so
okay so do you want me to search search
it and tell you what yeah yeah search it
and tell me what it is okay just the
word father in Aramaic two seconds take
as much as you need okay so it means
Ilah I don't know how to pronounce it
they say you didn't put in you put in
God you didn't put in Father put in
Father what is the Aramaic word exactly
if I put in Father it means ABA but you
know they they didn't call them they
didn't call God ABA you know it because
that's father hold on a second hold on a
second but he did though literally the
word ABA is in the Bible where Jesus
calls God ABA not Ella ABA he calls him
father okay okay I got your point okay
nice one so if you're telling me this it
it means I have to believe what's in the
in the Bible and this is a different
question do I believe what's in the in
the Bible wait wait hold on who brought
up the Bible you or me me I was like
give me the Ten Commandments and you
didn't give me the Comm so you went to
the Bible to try to prove that Jesus was
a
Muslim no I I didn't know no you're
taking I didn't say I I told you give me
the first ten commandments and then we G
we gave it out why why why did you say
why did you say give me the first
Commandments okay I'll tell you why
because because in one of them it tells
you to put God you're missing it what
did you say what did you say about the
first ten Comm the first of the Ten
Commandments what did you say about it
what what what what is the reason why
you brought that up okay so I brought it
up because the the question was uh is
Jesus a Palestinian Muslim and what did
you say about Jesus's teaching okay I
was like um his teachings uh and in the
first commandment he said you shall have
no other gods okay beautiful so you went
to the Bible to to show us what Jesus
taught in order to prove that he was a
Muslim in the Bible right yeah exactly
CU I was like from abrahamic view the
Bible got you so in that same Bible got
you Isaac in that same Bible what does
Jesus call his God look yeah exactly
this is where we're going why does it
say that first and then there cuz this
is why I have a contradiction I wouldn't
believe that why you're not answering
the question what does
call God could you could you let let me
answer could you let me answer it's a
simple question you can't talk over you
can't talk over me we have to have a
conversation you speak I'm GNA give you
eight seconds to answer yeah what did he
call so this is a way so he's gonna kick
me out in a bit this is what you're
going to do exactly this is what you're
going to do exactly we're not go we
can't answer the first question guys
this is where it clearly shows that you
are clearly running away cuz what does
the first commandment say you shall have
no other gods before me put God first
you're running away again exact just a
rambler